applaudissements pour olivier père
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
perfection sans doute pour certains
probablement mais dans ce voyage au bout
de moi même
ce sont surtout ses imperfections qui
m'ont permis de développer une forme de
pensée libre quand je souhaiterais vous
parler aujourd'hui
j'ai commencé par raté ma vie je déconne
pas l'âge de 23 ans
moi je voyais l'amour comme
l'aboutissement ultime la perfection
passé pour moi par le regard de cet
autre qui me sublimer tout est parti
d'un monde intérieur s'est effondré
j'étais fissure est un abîme s'ouvrait
sous mes pieds et le plus dur dans
toussaint pas ça a été de constater que
ma vie était ratée irrémédiablement raté
j'ai mis trois ans à m'en remettre à
poser des briques de vie l'une après
l'autre pour construire un édifice
nouveau après des études d'ingénieur je
partais deux ans en voyage et au retour
j'avais compris une chose le goût de
l'aventuré avait évincé l'idéal du coeur
je m'aventurais donc j'étais vivre à
passer par le voyage cet électrochoc
quelques années auparavant avait fait en
fait tomber en moi les barrières du
possible je n'avais plus rien à perdre
et c'était là le plus beau cadeau calme
à fait partant donc d'un constate
désastre je ne m'attendais à plus rien
de positif
et du coup tout ce qui m'arrive est
positif passer pour un bonus la vie est
devenu magique
il était temps pour moi de réveiller un
vieux rêve d'enfant vous savez ces
choses là c'est comme c'est comme un
dragon qui dort quand on le réveille on
sait jamais trop ce qui peut arriver
depuis l'âge de 14 ans je rêvais de
faire le tour du globe à vélo ça
prendrait du temps
trois ou quatre ans ça allait donc
suicide est littéralement ma carrière
d'ingénieur en aéronautique naissante
c'est donc tremblant de peur que je suis
allé voir mon chef grande peur devant
l'énormité de ce que j'allais commettre
et je lui ai annoncé que je partais t'es
sûr est sûre que tu fais pas une énorme
connerie la question à rester hantés m'a
hanté pendant des mois et des mois et
même des années durant
je le voyais un peu comme une
prospection vers le bas dans mon
imperfections de ma déprime post
amoureuse du coup tant qu'à faire une
erreur
autant la comète parfaitement et je me
suis donné une règle du jeu draconiennes
aucun moteur pour avancer et donc zéro
carbone non plus pour avancer je
traverserai les continents à vélo les
océans envoyé stop
et pour rajouter un petit peu de magie à
tout ça je prendrai avec moi un
parapente pour voir le monde d'en haut
ça a donné le projet en route avec elle
d'autres m'avait inspiré et d un peu à
soulever le tapis d impossible si elle
avait fait alors en y mettant du temps
et l'audace ben pourquoi pas moi
j'ai d'abord évidemment je les ai coupés
à ma manière puis j'ai d'abord suivi
puis parfois même dépassé mais m
l'aventurier mike horn lui m'avait
inspiré dans la voie du purisme dans le
thème du sang moyens motorisés avec son
aventure latitude zéro je vous amène
maintenant mars 2015
aux abords de la frontière chinoise j'ai
devant moi 140 kilomètres d'une zone
complètement interdites aux vélos sujet
des check points de l'armée un petit peu
de partout et en même temps ça fait des
années que je [ __ ] est donc à la fois
hors de question que je passe et que je
ne passe pas là-dessus j'avise un
occidental qui refuse justement de cette
direction et je lui demande comment ces
conditions un petit peu plus loin et
enfin je suis parle un petit peu de mon
projet et là il me dit il me déconseille
formellement de tenter le coup
d'abord puis de prendre plutôt un taxi
et et puis il me dit que en fait lui il
est passé il a passé 30 jours en russie
dans une prison à cause d'une idiotie du
même genre
c'est là c'est là que j'ai reconnu mike
horn
mike horn lui même me disait de prendre
un taxi je pouvait considérer cela comme
une absolution quasi divine on peut dire
donc du coup la journée passe le soir
tombe et je vais pour prendre un taxi et
le dernier moment je me ravise
j'enfourche mon vélo et je passe les 140
kilomètres dans une route de montagne de
nuit je passe les check points endormi
personne ne me voit j'arrive à la
frontière kirghize au petit matin
j'envoie un message à mike en lui disant
j'ai réussi lui me répond aussitôt yes
go go go et j'ai droit à ces
félicitations en direct en ne suivant
pas les recommandations mike horn en
allant complètement à l'encontre même de
ces recommandations
mike était quand même la référence pour
moi j'ai en fait compris à ce moment
là que nos modèles pouvaient nous
inspirer non seulement à suivre leur
chemin mais aussi finalement à chercher
notre propre chemin car il me fallait
juste oser d'essayer a essayé en fait
même sa 9e c'est que c'est carrément
obligatoire d'essayer dans la vie ça
devrait même être inscrits en discipline
obligatoire au bac si vous me demandez
le premier coup de [ __ ] fut à la fois
pour moi le plus difficile et le plus
convaincant si j'avais fait celui là
alors le reste ne serait plus que
répétition parfois certes on se loupe
arrivée en australie après cinq ans sur
les routes et ben j'étais lassé de
[ __ ] et oui ça arrive et j'ai eu
l'idée de me faire tractée par un
cerf-volant sur les immenses route du
désert et du coup ce projet était plutôt
bien montée en amont avec le bon sponsor
le bon matériel et tu devant vous savez
tout ça les bons partenaires
c'est très très bien beaucoup de travail
et c'est quelle déconvenue en fait les
5000 km et scande t je n'arrivais à me
faire tracter que tu ressens 50 km avec
une belle dizaine de chutes et
finalement j'ai décidé d'abandonner
il fallait en tirer les leçons j'avais
poussé l'envi jusqu'à l'essai puis de
laisser jusqu'à l'échec mais sans cela
comment aurait su que cette idée n'était
finalement pas viable sans doute que je
l'aurais jamais su du coup c'était
vraiment la seule manière de le savoir
essayez provoque la confiance en soi on
se découvre ont fait émerger les
possibles du reste et surtout on agit
sur le monde est en fait au bout du
compte pas dans ce nouveau paradigme de
voyage à force d'essayer de réussir
d'avoir des échecs etc
j'ai compris que ma vie était devenue
perfection jusqu'au jour
ou trois ans après mon départ alors que
j'étais en nouvelle-zélande aux
antipodes peux chez ma petite soeur ma
terre mon cher frère je vais me marier
dans quelques mois j'ai trouvé un
amoureux et je voudrais célébrer ça avec
vous tous avec toi aussi
c'est dans six mois ici en france
revient
un jeune veau dérogé à la règle du sérum
hauteur pour rien au monde ni même
interrompre ma thèse de vie
le coup est rude je lui dis je lui dis
non ma soeur non ma soeur je pourrais
pas venir à ton mariage quelques
semaines passent dans une réflexion
familiale un ami prêtre nous fait
parvenir ses mots quand l'idéologie la
plus juste la plus belle devient
totalisante alors elle exclut toute
entorse à la règle et devient un nouveau
conformisme qui tue l'énergie l'imprévu
et c'est pourtant dans les marges que
souvent se tient la source qui nous a
fait partir
mes parents me demande alors ce qui m'a
fait partir sans mal un sacré débat
interne je peux vous dire
après quelques jours de pédalage prompt
à la méditation
le constat fini par s'imposer en moi ce
qui a fondé ce voyage est en fait mon
environnement d'avant l'entourage de
l'enfant que j'étais et non le seul rêve
que j'en avais fort de cette conclusion
j'ai décidé de faire un nid mans ce pas
de côté dans ma perfection établi
je suis rentré en avion pour six mois
et en agissant ainsi j'ai pu récemment
avec ma famille avec mes amis mais aussi
avec quelques sponsors et médias qui
m'avait suivi jusque là et au delà d'un
d'un nouveau matériel de quelques
articles de presse toujours bien prendre
cet encouragement venant de la société
que j'avais pourtant quitté était
fondamental car il nous redonnait une
utilité sociale en encourageant d'autres
à se lancer
tout cela m'a donné un immense souffle
pour terminer cette deuxième moitié du
tour du monde avec une énergie nouvelle
que je n'aurais peut-être pas eu sinon
l'aurais-je même terminé rien n'est
moins sûr ce qui l'est en revanche c'est
que pour toute idéologie qui nous mène
savoir retrouver l'humain en ou savoir
faire un pas de côté est fondamental
c'est celui ci qui nous apporte une
immense liberté
2727 jour soit 7 ans et demi après le
départ le 29 décembre 2015
après 105 mille kilomètres des milliers
de rencontre de tous les horizons
je franchis la ligne d'arrivée
infiniment heureux d'avoir pu accomplir
mon rêve mais surtout en fait d'en avoir
touché les limites
j'ai appris que la question du doute de
l'imperfection n'a pas lieu d'être
ce sont les premiers pas un certain d'en
laisser des grandes choses que l'on peut
accueillir avec inquiétude son destin
c'est ainsi que l'on construit son
bonheur apprenons à rater notre vie avec
élégance
voilà le chemin vers une plus belle
acceptation du réel et vers une pensée
libre merci
[Applaudissements]